[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara höll
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag an meiner seite ist
munition für den sport hallo schön
genannt und wir haben unter anderem
diese themen für sie
wahlkampfauftakt der union
kanzlerkandidat laschet warnt vor einem
linksruck nach der bundestagswahl
raus aus afghanistan die evakuierungen
kommen nur schleppend voran
tausende harren weiter am flughafen in
kabul aus
und glanzvolles comeback in berlin nach
sechs jahren sanierung gibt es in der
neuen nationalgalerie jetzt wieder
moderne kunst zu sehen
ich habe keinen bock auf opposition so
drückte es heute csu chef markus söder
aus und sprach damit wohl allen in der
union aus der seele fünf wochen vor der
bundestagswahl sind die nerven
angespannt der gemeinsame
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet wird nicht
wirklich als zugpferd wahrgenommen die
umfragewerte sinken der offizielle
wahlkampfauftakt mit kanzlerin und
kandidat soll jetzt die wende einläuten
aus berlin ines trams
lange standen sie nicht mehr als trio
auf der bühne heute nun demonstrieren
sie einigkeit die umfragewerte schlecht
armin laschet schwächelt als wahlkämpfer
ab heute nun soll gemeinsam gekämpft
werden und mit klarer kante gegen rot
und grün ich werde kämpfen mit allem was
ich kann dass dieses land nicht von
ideologen übernommen wird wir wollen
regieren nicht weil wir regieren wollen
weil wir lust haben am regieren sondern
weil wir regieren müssen damit
deutschland einen guten weg er spricht
sich gegen steuererhöhungen aus für
einen wirtschaftsfreundlichen kampf
gegen den klimawandel
er warnt vor einer mehrheit links von
der union vor spd grünen und linken
insbesondere in außenpolitisch bewegten
zeiten er erwarte dass sie aufhören mit
diesem geht nicht diesen bedenken tragen
wir müssen zur sicherheit deutschlands
in dieser instabilen welt unseren
beitrag leisten und dafür sind wir
bereits
laschets bisheriger wahlkampf geprägt
von unglücklichen bildern hände in den
taschen im hochwasser statement vor
einem müllberg sein lachen während der
bundespräsident leid und tod bedauert
angela merkel gibt laschet heute
rückendeckung
ihm war und ist es immer wichtig auf der
grundlage unseres christlichen
menschenbildes den einzelnen menschen
mit seiner unantastbaren würde in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen
zwischen den menschen brücken zu bauen
der der nicht kanzlerkandidat geworden
ist stichelt hinter den kulissen in der
partei rumort es ein wechsel des
kandidaten wird diskutiert markus söder
fordert einen energischeren wahlkampf
bekennt sich heute aber zu lassen ich
will dass armin laschet kanzler wird und
nicht olaf scholz oder anna lena
es ist nichts verloren wie manche schon
schreiben es gibt keinen anlass zu
jammern sondern es ist die zeit endlich
zu kämpfen ich habe keine lust keinen
bock auf opposition liebe freundin
freunde noch 36 tage bis zur wahl die
zeit wird knapp für laschet das ruder
herumzureißen
holen wir theo koll in berlin dazu der
wahlkampf läuft bislang denkbar schlecht
für armin laschet war das heute der
große befreiungsschlag
zumindest hat sie noch kanzlerin heute
schon mal zum nächsten kanzler erklärt
das dürfte angesichts der beliebtheit
von angela merkel zumindest hilfreich
sein ansonsten war die rede trotz der
zugeschriebenen großen bedeutung
erstaunlich unspektakulär bemerkenswert
fand ich dass armin laschet jetzt
angesichts der schlechten umfragewerte
offensichtlich stärker auf die
kernwählerschaft der union ziel die
polizei stärken die strukturen von
klaren kriminalität zerstören es brauche
einen nationalen sicherheitsrat der csu
chef hat dagegen mehr rhetorische kraft
geboten er versprach ehrliche
unterstützung um dann gleich mehrfach
kritisch zu fordern jetzt müsse es aber
endlich vernünftigen wahlkampf geben und
klare führung eine bayerische dauer
beschwerde zwar ohne anschrift aber die
war heute auch nicht nötig wenn muss die
union jetzt am stärksten ins visier um
an der macht zu bleiben
das war hochinteressant und zwar was
gesagt wurde und vor allem was
verschwiegen wurde armin laschet hat
sehr deutlich vor rot rot grün und
linken ideologen gewarnt und erforderte
von olaf scholz sich zu bekennen dass er
nicht mit der linkspartei regieren werde
die viel wahrscheinlichere koalition
ohne die union aber ist eine ampel das
heißt die union müsste eigentlich auf
all ihre möglicherweise zur fdp
abwandern wähler ziehen und sie warnen
dass stimmen für die fdp auch in einer
ampel landen können dieses szenario wird
zwar hier hinter den cdu kulissen
gestreut aber diese viel größere union
sorge die wurde heute zumindest
öffentlich kaum thematisiert danke nach
berlin theo koll war das
schauen wir auf die weite bedrückende
lage in afghanistan als letztes
schlupfloch aus dem machtbereich der
taliban sehen weiter tausende den von
soldaten abgeriegelten flughafen in
kabul nur wenige haben dokumente die
ihnen einen platz in einem der nato
flieger verschaffen und 17.000 ausländer
und afghanen die für internationale
organisationen und das militär
gearbeitet haben sind bisher außer
landes gebracht worden davon mehr als
2000 von bundeswehrmaschinen glück war
bot berichtet auch heute belagerten
wieder tausende die völlig überlaufenen
zugänge zum flughafen und versuchen
verzweifelt ins innere zu gelangen
die große unruhe bringen all die vielen
menschen ohne dokumente rein sie haben
praktisch keine chance auf einlass
das auswärtige amt meldete am morgen die
tore seien derzeit geschlossen der
andrang offenbar zu gefährlich es sei im
moment sichere zu hause zu bleiben
schrieb die deutsche botschaft in der
nacht trafen die hubschrauber die die
evakuierungs operation unterstützen
sollen in kabul ein auch amerikanische
bürger wurden heute von ihrer botschaft
informiert den flughafen zu meiden an
den zufahrtsstraßen waren zahlreiche
weitere menschen aus ich habe in der
zeitung gelesen dass afghanen asyl
erhalten im ausland die lage hier ist
schlecht deshalb versuche ich so schnell
wie möglich weg zu kommen
in den straßen kabuls sind die menschen
vorsichtig berichte über gewalt
übergriffe und plünderungen machen die
runde frauen sollen wegen angeblich und
süchtiger kleidung von taliban
geschlagen worden sein
regierungsmitarbeiter würden gejagt
heißt es die menschen verunsichert
die taliban müssten jetzt schnell eine
regierung bilden wir brauchen hier
dringend sicherheit stabilität und auch
arbeitsplätze
die führung der radikalislamisten
dementierte berichte wonach sie
regierungsmitarbeiter verhaftet hätten
auch übergriffe gegen frauen werde man
nicht dulden sagte ein sprecher
hochrangige dschihadisten führer beraten
inzwischen über die bildung einer
übergangsregierung
unter ihnen auch der terrorist halil
hakkani der für zahlreiche
terroranschläge mit dutzenden toten in
afghanistan verantwortlich ist und von
den usa steckbrieflich gesucht wird
pagani zeigte sich in begleitung
schwerbewaffneter kommandokräfte in
kabul auf dem marktplatz
inzwischen werden die ausgeflogenen
menschen auf immer mehr länder verteilt
die amerikaner nutzen dabei die
luftwaffenbasis im pfälzischen ramstein
als eine der drehscheiben hier sind
bereits mehrere transportmaschinen
gelandet die mehr als 1000 evakuierten
werden vorübergehend in hangars und
zelten untergebracht bei madrid hat die
eu ein erstaufnahmelager eingerichtet
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
sagte die eu wolle auch in afghanistan
die humanitäre hilfe für die menschen
fortsetzen
zur corona pandemie um der impfkampagne
mehr schub zu geben möchte
arbeitsminister heil auch impfungen
während der arbeitszeit erlauben eine
entsprechende verordnung kündigte er in
der augsburger allgemeinen an bisher ist
es so dass arbeitnehmer keinen anspruch
darauf haben während der arbeitszeit
geimpft zu werden die zahlen steigen
derweil weiter das rk ii meldet 8000 92
neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind
2448 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen binnen eines tages 17 todesfälle
dazu die sieben tage incidents liegt
erstmals seit mai wieder über 50
wer soll eine auffrischimpfung bekommen
mehr klarheit und genaue vorgaben in
dieser sache fordert der chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
gassen in der rheinischen post
selbstverständlich könnten die praxen
die puste impfungen spritzen aber die
bundesregierung müsse sagen für wen und
wann sie sinnvoll sein
gesundheitsminister sparen hatte allen
bürgern eine auffrischung in aussicht
gestellt
in australien wächst der unmut gegen die
strengen chor ohne einschränkungen der
regierung tausende menschen sind deshalb
auf die straßen gegangen
melbourne und sydney kam es dabei zu
zusammenstößen mit der polizei mehr als
200 menschen wurden festgenommen
in sydney beispielsweise dürfen die
menschen seit mehr als zwei monaten ihre
wohnungen nur in dringenden fällen
verlassen diese harte lockdown wurde nun
bis ende september verlängert
am
26 september wird nicht nur die
bundestagswahl spannend sondern auch die
wahl zum berliner abgeordnetenhaus
seit fünf jahren regiert dort rot rot
grün doch spd bürgermeister müller tritt
nicht mehr an und wer ihm folgen wird
ist ziemlich offen vom wahlkampfauftakt
in der hauptstadt berichtet stephan
merseburger
sie will für die spd das rote rathaus
verteidigen franziska giffey wegen
plagiatsvorwürfen als familienministerin
zurückgetreten trotzdem möchte sie
nachfolgerin vom regierende
bürgermeister michael müller werden ihr
programm unsere fünf bis für berlin
bauen bildung beste wirtschaft
bürgernahe verwaltung und berlin in
sicherheit für eine soziale und sichere
metropole für eine zukunftsfähige und
lebenswerte stadt sie will als erste
grüne das rathaus erobern bettina
jarasch vom realo-flügel ohne
senatorenposten und daher dies ein manko
in der stadt kaum bekannt wir wollen die
stadt umbauen zu grünen und klimaneutral
metropole dass es dringend notwendig
wenn wir die erkenntnisse des
weltklimarats ernst nehmen das bedeutet
mehr entwickelte flächen mehr stadtgrün
mehr bäume auch cdu-spitzenkandidat kai
wegner kennen etwa 60 prozent der
berliner nicht er will aus der
opposition an die macht bildung mieten
neubau sicherheit und verwaltung alles
soll besser werden
ich möchte dass wir die probleme beheben
und ich will dafür sorgen dass berlin
eine stadt ist die an einstellen
funktioniert und dafür brauchen wir
keine ideologie sondern pragmatismus
gesunder menschenverstand mehr
miteinander
klaus lederer ist spitzenkandidat der
linken und zurzeit kultursenator
wahlkampftermin in einer ehemaligen
brauerei die jetzt von der
krisengeplagten clubszene genutzt wird
berlin soll bezahlbar bleiben für die 85
prozent mieterinnen und mieter aber auch
für das handwerk kleingewerbe aber vor
allem auch für kunst und kultur solche
orte die den charme der stadt ausmacht
die drohen verloren zu gehen christine
brinker ist spitzenkandidatin der afg
lange tobte ein erbitterter machtkampf
in der partei zwischen gemäßigten und
radikalen am ende setzte sich durch
berlin muss wieder normal werden berlin
braucht mehr sicherheit in den tags
berlin braucht eine vernünftige bildung
für unsere kinder
berlin braucht viel viel mehr wohnungen
holen wir uns die zukunft ist die losung
von sebastian czaja seine fdp will nach
mehr als 30 jahren endlich mal wieder
mitregieren wir wollen einen mietwagen
eine neue offensive in der stadt weil
das beantwortet die soziale frage
unserer zeit 200.000 neue wohnungen
müssen dringend gebaut werden wir
möchten die verwaltung modernisieren
damit die unternehmen sich hier
ansiedeln der kampf ums rote rathaus
wird spannend rot rot grün rot schwarz
gelb jamaika diese koalitionen scheinen
in berlin möglich
nach haiti dort sind die menschen eine
woche nach dem verheerenden erdbeben
verzweifelt noch immer kommt die hilfe
nur schleppend voran in der besonders
schwer getroffenen stadt liegt hunderte
überlebende an den konvoi der reis an
die opfer der katastrophe verteilen
sollte das beben der stärke 7,2 hatte
zehntausende häuser zerstört die
behörden sprechen von rund 2200 toten
noch immer werden hunderte menschen
vermisst
seit tagen schon zieht tropensturm grace
seine kreise jetzt ist er erneut auf die
küste mexikos getroffen
er brachte windgeschwindigkeiten bis zu
175 kilometer in der stunde und jede
menge regen mit die behörden warnen vor
erdrutschen und überschwemmungen
und auch der nordosten der usa bereitet
sich auf einen schweren sturm vor
hurrikan henry könnte am sonntag die
küste erreichen
zurück nach berlin und zu einem
wichtigen tag für die deutsche
museumslandschaft
die neue nationalgalerie erbaut in den
60er jahren von bauhaus ikone mies van
der rohe feiert ihre wiedereröffnung
jahre lang war die berühmte glas und
stahlkonstruktion saniert worden für 140
millionen euro moderne architektur für
moderne kunst henriette de maizière
eröffnung in zeiten der pandemie
auch die sanierung und auch die kunst
auf die kunst nach sechs jahren
sanierung hat berlin seinen tempel der
moderne wieder die neue nationalgalerie
sie wird kraft die von diesem gebäude
ausgeht diese klarheit auch diese
autorität stehe am rande des
kulturforums und doch immer im
mittelpunkt diese wirkung wird dieses
gebäude wieder entfalten die mobile
alexander kohl das bespielen zum auftakt
die gläserne halle von mies van der rohe
minimal maximal ist eine von drei
ausstellungen mit denen sich die neue
nationalgalerie zurück meldet ein haus
mit eleganz und leichtigkeit eröffnet
1968 das werk des von den nazis ins
amerikanische exil vertriebenen
architekten mies van der rohe im
spannungsfeld von kunst und
zeitgeschichte
es steht auf der schnittstelle zwischen
ost und westberlin und es beheimatet
eine sammlung die er die ganzen brüche
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts des großen
deutschen bitteren aber auch strahlenden
jahrhunderts erzählt von brüchen
umbrüchen und aufbrüchen erzählen die
gemälde und skulpturen der sammlung aus
den jahren 1900 bis 1945 und offenbaren
ihn den zusammenhang kunst und
gesellschaft
morgen öffnet die neue nationalgalerie
ihre türen für das publikum
eintritt pandemie bedingt nur mit vorher
gebuchten tickets
und jetzt fußball rudi borussia dortmund
hat gerade keinen guten lauf wie auch
nicht in der bundesliga er muss dortmund
am zweiten spieltag erneut eine
enttäuschung hinnehmen vier tage nach
dem 1 3 im supercup gegen meister bayern
münchen unterliegt der bvb überraschend
dem sc freiburg hier sind die samstags
ergebnisse freiburg gewinnt gegen
dortmund 2 zu 1 torlos die begegnung
eintracht frankfurt gegen augsburg zwei
minuten vor schluss gelingt wolfsburg
der siegtreffer zum 2 1 bei hertha bsc
gelungenes heim comeback für aufsteiger
bochum 2 0 gegen mainz greuther fürth
bielefeld trennen sich 1 1 gestern sieht
leipzig gegen vfb stuttgart mit 4 0 das
abendspiel leverkusen gegen gladbach
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio
noch wenig aussagekraft hat die tabelle
wolfsburg führt sie erst mal an mit zwei
siegen vor freiburg hoffenheim leipzig
und dortmund
die durch corona personal geschwächten
mainzer sind auf 9 die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit arminia
bielefelds bayern münchen auf dem elften
kann sich morgen natürlich verbessern
härter mit zwei niederlagen letzter
angelique kerber verpasst die revanche
für die halbfinal-niederlage in
bündelten gegen ashley partie aus
australien man masters turnier in
cincinnati verliert sie in der runde der
letzten vier gegen die
weltranglisten-erste in zwei sätzen mit
2 6 und 5 7
kerber wird dennoch kommende woche
wieder in den top 20 der weltrangliste
geführt werden zum ersten mal seit
eineinhalb jahren und keines
olympiasieger alexander zverev hingegen
steht im halbfinale von cnet der
hamburger gewinnt gegen den norweger
kastelruth mit 6 zu 1 und 6 3
an solche bilder kann man sich bei
alexander zverev gewöhnen denn wie auch
gegen den chancenlosen norweger caspary
immerhin weltranglisten elfter ist der
hamburger inklusive olympia im neunten
match nacheinander für seine gegner zu
stark im ersten aufeinandertreffen mit
ruth lässt es wäre von beginn an keinen
zweifel an seiner zurzeit überragenden
form und froh dass ich noch einem
halbfinale bin ich denke morgen wird es
ein sehr spannendes match werden ich
denke es sind zwei spieler die in guter
form sind und vor den jusos ist es auch
ein sehr wichtiges match nach diesem
klaren 6 2 1 und 6 2 gegen ried trifft
zverev nun auf den griechen stefano
skipass gegen den er unlängst bei den
french open noch denkbar knapp in fünf
sätzen unterlegen war
wäre stark der hat einen guten luft sie
laden heute noch mal herrlich
sommerliche temperaturen doch schon
heute nacht beginnt es von westen
kräftig zu regnen und zu gewittern mehr
dazu hat gleich katja horneffer viertel
vor elf freut sich bettina schausten auf
sie im heute journal und wir freuen uns
wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind einen
schönen samstagabend wünsche ich ihnen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
benannt nach dem sommerlichen samstag
kommt jetzt gewitter tiefen manfred und
bringt kräftige regenfälle mit zum teil
mit unwetter durchsetzt und das mit den
gewittern das geht schon heute nacht los
dann gewitter zwischen
nordrhein-westfalen und
baden-württemberg bis zum frühen morgen
erreichen die regenfälle auch franken
und niedersachsen dabei sinken die
temperaturen in der nacht auf 18 bis 12
grad und steigen morgen über tag auf 18
bis 24 grad an der ostseeküste gibt es
morgen an kräftigem ostwind erhält so
ein bisschen gegen das tief deswegen
zeigt sich dort am längsten die sonne
den kräftigsten dauerregen gibt es hier
vom nördlichen brandenburg bis ins
emsland 60 liter pro quadratmeter sind
da durchaus möglich in der mitte und im
süden weht dagegen ein westwind und der
treibt kräftige schauer und gewitter
über uns machen sie sich auf unwetter
gefasst also auf gewitter mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen und auch in der
kommenden woche geht es sehr wechselhaft
und kühler weiter und jetzt schauen wir
auf den ehemaligen tropensturm henry
inzwischen ist das ein hurrikan über dem
nordatlantik und er peilt new york city
und boston an und wenn er dort morgen
auf die küste trifft wird ist das erste
mal ein hurrikan in dieser region seien
seit 30 jahren guten abend